[Musique]
ont traversé les âges leur forêt les a
toujours nourri et préservées de la
modernité
aujourd'hui les Pygmées de République
centrafricaine semblent moins isolés
c'est leur univers suspendu entre deux
époques qu'un guide français va faire
découvrir à 5 touristes
travaille à la poste sa femme Agnès
était soignante elle est d'une nature
plutôt attentionnée ou est-ce qu'il y a
quand même des personnes qui décèdent de
la fièvre jaune
Christophe et Marie-Claude sont deux
alsaciens qui vivent en lisière de forêt
ils sont justement curieux dans
découvrir une autre
sentir toucher tactile
Marie-Hélène elle est commercial en
région parisienne volontiers maternelle
parfois moraliste notamment quand il
s'agit d'alcool
à ses affaires
et pour guider pas à pas ces cinq
Français il y a Olivier il explore cette
forêt depuis 17 ans
comment les Pygmées survivent-ils au
cœur de la forêt primaire qu'avons-nous
à apprendre de leur savoir millénaire ce
peuple des forêts a-t-il quelque chose à
gagner de cette nouvelle forme de voyage
que l'on appelle les notoriasme
récit d'une aventure déroutante ou de
montre que tout oppose se rencontrent au
détour d'un sentier
[Musique]
allez on démarre là c'est bien là on est
parti pour 15 jours d'aventure en total
autonomie
l'aventure comment sur le fleuve
houbongi au sud de la Centrafrique
les touristes sont impatients d'entrer
en forêt des Pygmées ils ne savent rien
nous presque Olivier va les préparer à
la rencontre et les mettre en garde
communiquer avec ces hommes des bois ne
sera pas chose facile entre 3 et 5 jours
vous verrez vos premiers ils ont un
regard très tendre très doux et tout de
suite on peut les reconnaître quoi
farouche craintif
apeuré parfois
déjà les premières inquiétudes Agnès
craint de passer pour une intruse
[Musique]
ils vont beaucoup vous observer l'air de
rien
vous allez voir il vous observe
énormément jour et nuit il voit très
bien la nuit hein
[Applaudissements]
voir des bêtes curieuses quoi parce que
pour moi c'est un côté voyeurisme et
j'ai pas du tout ce côté là je vais pas
qu'on perçoit mon voyage comme ça
avant d'apercevoir le premier pygmée il
faut naviguer plus de 200 km vers le sud
quitter la civilisation
[Musique]
là on arrive en territoire pygmées toute
cette partie de la forêt qui va jusqu'au
Congo c'est le territoire des Pygmées la
végétation est beaucoup plus dense on
voit plus du tout les berges vous voyez
qu'il y a plus un seul village et même
le climat change un petit peu là c'est
un peu plus droite un peu plus fine
nous arrivons à bataillemot l'un des
rares villages de la région c'est un peu
la porte d'entrée de la forêt
à chaque voyage Olivier fait appel à des
porteurs c'est ici qu'il les recrute
ces pygmées ont quitté la forêt pour
trouver du travail au village
il y a les deux djangote
un homme s'en prend au pic des recruter
il est visiblement jaloux de l'attention
dont ils font l'objet c'est un bantou
l'ethnie majoritaire de la région
les Bantous sont plutôt grands et
robustes et depuis des siècles ils
veulent soumettre les Pygmées plutôt
petits et réservés
[Musique]
les touristes s'impliquent et prennent
parti
[Rires]
Olivier va recruter une vingtaine de
porteurs uniquement des Pygmées
donc vous pouvez personne ne connaît
mieux la forêt que elle est leur mère
nourricière
Olivier n'emploie pas de Bantous qui
harcèlerait dès leur plus jeune âge les
pygmées
[Applaudissements]
votre premier contact avec les Pygmées
et déjà on voit qu'ils sont totalement
dénigrés incroyable un des gamins de 5
ans qui se moquent
incroyable leurs parents se voient des
Pygmées donc ils font pareil tout
simplement
pas qu'il nous parle
français qui disait c'est vraiment très
fort de la haine
premier choc pour les touristes cette
tension entre Bantous et pygmées ils
auront d'autres occasions de l'observer
au cours du voyage
[Musique]
pour l'heure il se prépare à entrer en
territoire pygmées
mais avant il faut régler un détail
pratique les porteurs ont besoin de sacs
pour transporter les bagages du groupe
et ça se règle en quelques coups de
machette
j'ai tenu de la façon qui font ça ils
sont habiles de leur ville de leurs
mains et puis
dans les bagages les vêtements des
Français et des cadeaux qu'Olivier a
prévu pour chaque campement
les Pygmées non eux aucune affaire
personnelle ils n'en n'ont pas besoin
les porteurs partent devant ils marchent
beaucoup plus vite au son de leurs
encouragements
[Musique]
les touristes doivent prendre leur
premier cours de survie
on va rencontrer de temps en temps une
colonne de fourmis maniant qui sont des
fourmis noirs assez redoutables qui
pince comme ça bon donc il faut courir
d'une certaine façon à grandes enjamber
donc là je vais vous montrer un petit
peu comment il faut faire il faut pas
lever les talons par derrière parce que
les fourmis vont remonter dans votre
nuqueuses
donc il faut courir à plat comme ça
d'accord
c'est drôle mais c'est comme ça
on va y aller
[Applaudissements]
c'est des informations comme ça tous les
10 minutes
[Musique]
c'est l'entrée en forêt le moment tant
attendu de tous ou redouter
[Musique]
une végétation luxuriante des arbres
gigantesques un touriste peut facilement
se sentir vulnérable
[Applaudissements]
on va bientôt arriver
et l'humidité
90% d'humidité 30 degrés et une soif qui
forcément vous tenaille les Pygmées vont
partager avec les touristes une première
astuce Comment se désaltérer en pleine
forêt en coupant une liane la mozambie
c'est vraiment de l'eau
Patrice est impressionné par tant de
connivence avec la nature
il y avait presque un cours de
développement durable
au point de vue de la consommation parce
que ils sont là depuis des millénaires
et la forêt elle est toujours là ils
prélèvent vraiment ce qu'ils ont besoin
pour vivre et ils sont pas matérialistes
ils vont pas couper les choses pour pour
en faire des babioles
pendant que les voyageurs s'émerveillent
des vertus de la mozambie le pisteur
Django s'éclipse
la saison du miel il a besoin d'un
panier pour le récolter
[Musique]
dès qu'il en aura l'occasion ils montera
aux arbres pour dénicher une ruche
allant croire un pygmée peut vivre
aujourd'hui encore en total autarcie ou
presque
[Musique]
autour de nous dans notre forêt
ce qui nous manque c'est surtout le
tabac et les vêtements c'est pour cela
que nous sommes obligés d'aller
travailler en ville pour gagner de
l'argent et ensuite faire nos achats
mais une fois que c'est terminé on
revient dans notre forêt
5 minutes pour tresser son panier et il
peut rejoindre les touristes
[Musique]
avant d'atteindre le bivouac il leur
reste une épreuve les fourmis tant
redoutées
c'est
pas plaisant
voici le premier campement pygmées
[Musique]
faites de feuilles et de branchages
l'assistant d'Olivier a repéré les lieux
il y a deux semaines
quand les voyageurs s'installent ils
sont observés à bonne distance le
dernier passage d'un blanc remonte à
plus de 10 ans c'était un missionnaire
donc tout va bien tu lui expliques qu'on
est gentil moi j'ai pas peur de toi
cette jeune pygmée n'a jamais vu de
blanc et la forêt fourmille de
superstitions
[Musique]
André l'assistant d'olivier et bantou
lui-même trouve la situation plutôt
drôle cette pygmée apeurée il veut la
montrer à ses amis de Bangui la capitale
des fantômes quoi c'est vrai
c'est ce qu'on dit oui mais qui dit ça
demande du tarte et de la pudeur
Marie-Hélène tente de rassurer les
Pygmées et peut-être aussi de dissiper
son embarras
de représenter les envahisseurs quoi
mais bon mais bon pour l'instant ils ont
ils sont plus impressionnés
c'est
quoi
la femme première nuit en pleine forêt
demain peut-être le contact sera plus
facile
au petit matin Olivier tient à remercier
les villagesois en leur offrant des
cadeaux de quoi se nourrir se laver et
surtout de quoi chasser
le guide s'adresse au chef qui les
redistribuera
il y a le sucre
il y a deux savants allumettes d'accord
deux paquets de bâtons blancs
ça te fait plaisir oui
les autres pygmées attendent son
broncher mais discrètement quelques
Bantous se faufilent
des Bantous des villes qui viennent au
campement acheter à bas prix des
produits de la forêt des Bantous qui se
servent sans demander
Olivier doit s'interposer pour défendre
les babingas c'est le nom des Pygmées
dans la langue des Bantous
acheter un bâtard facilement lui il ne
va pas me bâtard au village il ne va pas
il reste ici donc les cadeaux c'est pour
eux c'est pas excusez-moi c'est pas pour
vous vous êtes riche eux ils ont rien
non non tu vois ils n'ont rien à dire là
là la villageoise a pris ce qu'elle
voulait sur la planche et elle allait
partir avec
le chef n'avait rien à dire la religion
les bons tout imposent leur loi jusque
dans la forêt même si depuis des
millénaires elle est le territoire des
Pygmées
je vais vous donner à chacun de vous un
sifflet ça vous permettra de nous
prévenir si vous sentez que vous êtes
perdu
voilà très bien
le peuple des chasseurs se remet en
marche en imitant le cri des animaux
comme le veut la tradition pygmée
[Musique]
le prochain campement est à 4 heures de
marche pour les touristes une de moins
pour les porteurs malgré leur 25 kg de
charge
[Musique]
ses sentiers tous les Pygmées les
siennes dès qu'ils sont en âge de marché
pour gagner leur vie comme ces deux
journaliers que le groupe rencontre
c'est des porteurs vous voyez il y a un
tapis là qui vaillant parce qu'il porte
un sac qui est très lourd avec son fils
là qui porte aussi un sac qui est très
lourd
c'est des feuilles de coco qui sont
récoltées là par une villageoise qui
utilise des porteurs pygmées qui les
charges bien et qui les emmène au
village pour les vendre voilà quelqu'un
veut se peser le poids du sac
il va faire 40 kg tu vois facilement
un enfant au travail une rencontre
dérangeante qui peut jeter un froid sur
des vacances
c'est aussi ça l'ethno tourisme
les marchands qui recrutent cette main
d'oeuvre de tous âges les touristes vont
les rencontrer ici à Karawa
les porteurs sont arrivés il y a une
heure Agnès retrouve Paul avec qui elle
est devenue très complice
le campement est plus grand qu'hier plus
moderne aussi
les huttes traditionnelles des Pygmées
côtoient les maisons en dures des
paysans Bantous là vous voyez on vient
d'arriver à Karawa en plein milieu de
l'après-midi
là on voit toute une série de villageois
bantou et bon ils ont l'air de d'être
tranquille là ils attendent simplement
que leur travailleur pygmées qui sont
partis en forêt pour chercher des
feuilles de coco ils attendent tout
simplement que tous ces gens reviennent
en fin de journée et voilà donc ils sont
exploités voilà les exploiteurs
un rapport de maître à esclave qui
semble perdurer depuis des générations
Marie-Hélène aborde le sujet qui fâche
avec un bantou du village
apparemment les Pygmées et les Bantous
ça fait pas hein
[Musique]
comme leur chef ils disent que c'est
grâce à nous qu'on leur a montré le
chemin le savoir-vivre savoir les
héberger et en tout en leur donnant des
habits ça peut pas changer ça peut pas
changer pourquoi ça peut pas changer ça
peut pas changer parce que le pygmée est
trop obéissant parce que ce que vous ne
dépassez c'est dans le sang
qui soit insulter battu ou exploiter les
Pygmées ne portent jamais plainte les
commissariats sont trop loin de la forêt
ils n'ont pas de carte d'identité ni de
droit à la propriété
Django est l'un des rares avoir
fréquenté l'école primaire il a beau
être sûr de lui lui aussi craint les
Bantous
on a peur de ils sont plus grands et
plus forts que nous
moi je ne peux pas répondre aux insultes
d'un bantou je suis un pygmé je préfère
me taire
nous on ne peut pas rivaliser on ne peut
pas être légal des Bantous
c'est pas possible
on a toujours été leurs esclaves on est
des gens d'en bas et on restera toujours
des gens d'en bas
les Français posent des questions qui
dérangent ils détontent aussi certains
pygmées du travail que les Bantous
aimeraient voir achever les touristes
commencent à se demander si leur
présence ne desserre pas les Pygmées ils
veulent en discuter avec eux à l'abri
des regards
est-ce que les Bantous par exemple
peuvent se venger sur les Pygmées pour
le parce qu'on est venu nous voir
on va avoir des problèmes pas mal
peut-être même quand on ira les voir
pour se faire payer on leur dira que le
travail a été fait bien avancé et eux
nous diront je te paierai plus tard elle
ne voudront pas nous écouter
et puis peut-être qu'il me prendront
quelque chose il me voleront mes
affaires c'est comme ça que les ennuis
commencent
demande-leur qu'est-ce que voilà en quoi
c'est important qu'on vienne les voir
ce sujet là
vous pouvez nous aider on nous donnant
des cadeaux en nous donnant des
vêtements les cadeaux ça nous fait très
très plaisir à nous à nos familles à
tout le village
ça nous fait beaucoup réfléchir on en
était même à dire avec Olivier voilà
est-ce qu'il faut continuer à venir les
voir si c'est pour après qui est concret
autant de problèmes moi
je pense
ça peut avoir un effet bénéfique pour
les Pygmées parce que c'est les valoris
quand même que les gens qui faisaient
des millions de kilomètres pour venir
les voir qui prennent position donc
c'est petit mais
mais se sentent moins seul dans le
rapporter quelque chose et puis
quelque chose voilà
le secret de la discussion en tout cas
tous ces questionsnements intéressants
étrange voyage dont le bienfondé même
est mis en doute par ses participants
c'est pourtant un voyage équitable si
pour cent du prix payé 2800 euros par
personne doit être reversé à des projets
d'adopigmé
[Musique]
ce soir les Pygmées vivent un événement
inédit Olivier a transformé leur
campement en cinéma de plein air
au programme un documentaire des années
les Pygmées découvrent une technique
aujourd'hui disparue celle de leurs
ancêtres
la plupart n'ont jamais vu de films il
n'y a pas d'électricité donc pas de
télévision dans leur campement le public
est captivé
[Applaudissements]
on est en plein milieu de Centrafrique
j'observe plus les gens que le cinéma
à fond
dans cette société qui ne connaît pas
l'image le savoir se transmet uniquement
à l'oral
le souvenir des aïeux n'a survécu qu'à
travers les récits des anciens
sur l'écran les pygmées sont nus ou
presque quand ceux d'aujourd'hui sont
tous habillés
Marie-Hélène est intrigué
n'avaient pas de vêtements pourquoi ils
ont besoin d'un pantalon d'une chemise
maintenant c'est parce que
si on se précipite pour s'habiller à la
vue d'un étranger c'est par respect pour
lui
on ne peut pas rester le torse nu c'est
ce qu'on nous a appris
ce qui leur apprend justement
ce sont les Bantous qui nous apprennent
qu'il faut se couvrir devant les
étrangers
il est une tradition que les Pygmées
n'abandonnerait pour rien au monde la
danse et le chant
ses chants millénaires l'UNESCO les a
même classées au patrimoine culturel de
l'humanité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les touristes se lancent timidement
[Rires]
les Pygmées eux ne leur prête déjà plus
attention pas plus qu'à Olivier
[Musique]
ce sont ces moments très précieux que le
guide vient chercher ici chaque année
j'habite au milieu du clairière la
plupart de l'année
et je me retrouve ici un peu comme chez
moi nous nous consommons comme des
idiots et un jour on va le payer et eux
vont le payer d'ailleurs pour nous
également donc si on apprenait beaucoup
plus de choses deux de leur mode de vie
on n'irait pas droit dans le mur comment
le va actuellement
[Musique]
il est 6h du matin la nature s'éveille
tout le campement travaille déjà la
feuille de coco
tout le campement ou presque
le réveil est difficile ces vacances
sans aucun confort sont tous offres aux
dire que pour 2800 euros ils auraient pu
se payer un hôtel de luxe
super bien quoi parce que le soir il
faut la fête longtemps et puis le matin
ça y est ça commence à bouger dans le
cancan c'est vrai que des fois on se dit
on est un peu fou depuis autant pour
dormir oui dans un camping mais c'est
tellement génial c'est une aventure
tellement humaine
les porteurs sont debout depuis l'aube
et les voyageurs sont aussitôt
sollicités
certains porteurs ont des plaies au dos
à cause de leur charge très vite tout le
monde se presse dans ce dispensaire
improvisé j'ai mal au dos quand je porte
je sens la fatigue je voudrais savoir si
la maman peut me donner quelque chose
mais donner un médicament à un habitant
de la forêt n'est pas un geste anodin
surtout pour une aide-soignante
les médicaments ça a double tranchant
parce qu'ils ont pas l'habitude de nos
médicaments avec les substances
chimiques c'est que du naturel donc
est-ce bien de leur donner par contre
qui c'est qui a de l'eau pour après
discussion BO Simba reçoit quand même un
comprimé de paracétamol avec de l'eau
est-ce qu'ils ont des remèdes dans la
forêt comment ils se soignent quand on
n'est pas là avec nos moyens
pour répondre à Agnès le chef du
campement accepte de dévoiler quelques
secrets
une demi-heure de marche plus tard il
s'arrête au pied de cet arbre le mot que
ça
il fournit au pigment une pommade pour
cicatriser les plaies
quelques copeaux des Corses mêlés à de
la sève et le baume est prête à l'emploi
mettons à une plaie tu le mets sur la
peau et il le laisse combien de temps
comment elle le font tenir il suffit de
l'appliquer sur la peau ça colle tout
seul tu le gardes trois jours et en une
semaine tu es guéri comment il sait que
c'est cet arbre là qu'il faut venir
chercher l'écorce comment il a trouvé
l'arbre là quelqu'un lui a
Montréal
ça vient de nos ancêtres
moi c'est mon père qui me l'a appris
et moi même je l'ai appris à mon fils
mais sont fiers de nous montrer sortant
pour un instant de leur timidité
la pharmacie chez nous est quand même
plus accessible ils sont 15000 pygmées à
vénéré cette forêt sans elle pas d’eau
pas de médicaments pas de nourriture et
c'est précisément cette forêt
nourricière qui pour Django le porteur
est menacé par les grandes sociétés
forestières
cet arbre là c'est un sapélie
il est très important pour nous nous
procure beaucoup de chenilles que nous
vendons ensuite sur les marchés c'est
notre activité traditionnelle elle nous
aide à vivre
aujourd'hui les forestiers abattent ces
arbres il y en a de moins en moins et
nous nous devons marcher de plus en plus
loin pour récolter nos chenilles
qui sont ces coupeurs d'arbres que
Django accuse
aussi étrange que cela puisse paraître
Olivier a inscrit au programme la visite
d'une scierie elle n'est qu'à quelques
kilomètres de la forêt de Django
[Musique]
son patron est un français André de
Sousa il a dirige depuis 25 ans
exportation
[Musique]
là c'est la France
chaque année sa société débite ici pour
3 millions d'euros de bois exotiques nos
voyageurs vont s'improviser porte-parole
des Pygmées et encore une fois c'est
Marie-Hélène qui met les pieds dans le
plat obligeant le patron à se défendre
pendant certaines années
de la forêt alors que c'est vous les
premiers écologistes c'est nous parce
que la forêt c'est notre maman celle qui
nous nourrit c'est elle qui nous donne
du travail est-ce que vous replantez
pour
ta taxes
est-ce que vous tenez compte des
populations pygmées qui vivent dans ces
forêts comment vous faites pour
respecter ce périmètre dont ils ont
besoin voilà pour vivre comme ils ont
toujours vécu en autonomie et
comment c'est possible ça
silence embarrassé du directeur ce que
fait l'état centrafricain de sa taxe ce
n'est pas son problème
Marie-Hélène elle veut croire que ces
questions ne resteront pas sans effet
je suis pas sûr qu'il est vraiment
conscience qu'il oblige les populations
pygmées à vivre différemment à cause de
la déforestation peut-être qu'on lui a
apporté une question qui auquel il
pourrait réfléchir c'est possible
demain matin les touristes qui seront la
forêt leur voyage touche à sa fin
5 euros quotidiens ça paraît bien peu
mais c'est 6 fois plus que leur salaire
habituel
je te donne la
avec cet argent je veux acheter des
habits pour ma femme des marmites des
gobelets
je voudrais aussi faire évoluer ma vie
et surtout celle de mes enfants
avec l'argent que je gagne
salaire en poche les porteurs pour
cacher leur billet ils craignent de se
faire détrousser par les Bantous
Django ne s'attarde pas il préfère
marcher dans la nuit noire et être au
plus vite en lieu sûr
le lendemain à l'aube l'ambiance est à
la boisson certains porteurs ont but
toute la nuit ils ont laissé une partie
de leur salaire
mon bac à lui à l'alcool triste il s'est
fait voler dans son sommeil le reste de
son argent
en guise de consolation une petite leçon
de morale
ah ouais
la prochaine fois tu fais attention tu
bois pas trop boire
le groupe quitte les porteurs sur cette
note un peu triste direction Bangui la
capitale de Centrafrique
là dans les quartiers populaires à
l'écart du centre-ville ils vont
rencontrer des Pygmées qui ont choisi un
autre chemin
c'est moins 1 au facteur de X pour
Jérôme et ses camarades c'est l'heure
des devoirs une ONG de Bangui qui les a
repérés prend en charge gratuitement
leur éducation ils sont lycéens ou
étudiants l'école est pour eux l'unique
moyen de devenir des citoyens à part
entière ils veulent devenir médecin
professeur ou avocats mais cette
ambition a un prix
en s'installant en ville ils ont laissé
un peu de même dans la forêt j'ai
beaucoup perdu la traduction la majorité
des choses que je ne sais pas quoi par
exemple
faire la chasse à arbalète comment
lancer la flèche il y a beaucoup de
choses que j'ai perdu c'est un sacrifice
je veux je dois me sacrifier pour pour
les aider
les touristes ont voulu faire leurs
connaissances
à la fin de leur voyage après temps de
rencontre parfois dérangeantes ils n'ont
plus qu'une question en tête est-ce
qu'ils pensent qu'ils doivent rester
dans la forêt ou est-ce qu'ils doivent
sortir de la forêt pour être
plus civilisé entre guillemets les
pigments
ombilical avec la forêt même moi qui
suis ici quand je vois cette forêt là
je vais je rentre même de moments où
pour trouver quelque chose pour me
ressourcer voilà pour me laisser voir
vraiment mes senti au moins que je suis
je suis chez moi quoi
parce qu'on retrouve toujours ce regard
très très doux
ils ont vraiment un regard
attirant enfin persan et vraiment c'est
émouvant et là on va partir
[Applaudissements]
rester dans une forêt menacée ou quitter
cette forêt pour mieux la défendre pour
ces jeunes pygmées le dilemme est cruel
quant au touriste il repartent en se
demandant si le Royal aura réellement
profité au pygmées
[Applaudissements]
pour ces derniers un millier d'euros
devrait être investi avec l'argent de
l'etnotourisme
la somme contribuera à préserver une
culture millénaire une culture de plus
en plus ouverte aux visiteurs et de plus
en plus fragile
[Applaudissements]